I think it is interesting that the
Russian issue certainly shifted away
from markets attention and I think there
were two reasons for it one of course is
we've seen quite a bounce in the oil
price and at the end of the day Russian
markets have always of course heavily
influenced by that and secondly and
maybe this is just Tempe but of course
the fighting in Ukraine and the latest
sea fire cease fire appears to have sort
of held I I constantly keep at the back
of the mount of my mind something that
ex finance ministers of Kudrin said to
me a couple of years ago and I last saw
him that very strangely he predicted to
me that at some stage Putin would become
a very different character than we all
often think of him and I ended up sort
of to myself the past few months joking
that humanity would be even crazier than
he's been but I think he actually meant
it be shifting course so you know I
don't think it's necessarily as
predictable as we all often super
visually thing and I think the general
view is it's just a matter of time
before they all start fighting again and
then the next minute rushes back in
there in the heat of market pressure but
you know I don't know if that's true
because certainly when people are
looking for value investments around the
world
Russia is is obviously from a currency
inequity perspective very cheap compared
to anywhere else I was speaking another
event the other day and I was looking at
the total returns of all the BRIC equity
markets from 13 and a half years ago and
by the way it's quite interesting
despite Russia's problems still stronger
returns in dollar terms than the US and
the rest of the world and but the point
of our eyes it is India is so
spectacularly outperforms now the other
three that a valued person will be
looking at selling India and buying
Russia and Brazil but I don't see a
spark for that but if we continue to see
a calming of the tensions and oil prices
just a remaining stable and I think you
might see some people trying to viral
[ __ ] to be honest Jim where exactly
mostly inclines that way where does that
leave China sorry to have gone yeah I
remain I mean a much more sanguine about
China than I see so many people making
reference to yes the latest date is soft
and there may be we're growing below the
7% target that the president just
recently announced I'm actually going to
spend the whole or next week there so
I'm very much looking forward to that
but uh you know the key is that there is
slow evidence of rebalancing going on a
couple of things to cite this very
interesting report in the media this
morning that the climate change
emissions have started to actually show
signs of being better than expected in
2014 main reason being China is doing a
lot better on emissions control than
expected which is an important part of
why China is slowing because it's
deliberate second in some ways even more
substantive thing if you look at the
latest data and everyone is so excited
about the weakness of industrial
production retail sales spending which
is not a perfect but the only monthly
indicator we've got off consumption
continues to hold up pretty well and
what what China's really focused on
policy wise is of course the rebalancing
of consumption relative to production as
within a framework of better quality of
growth so yes they've got quite a lot of
challenges particularly related to bad
debts and property prices slowing but I
think generally speaking China's ongoing
performance is pretty impressive